- Interns,
it's not what you're going
to learn this summer.
As a matter of fact,
94% of you are gonna
take jobs where
they're gonna teach
you dumbass shit
or stuff that you already know.
They're mailing in
their internships.
Interns, it's not about what
you're going to learn
this summer, my friends,
it's going to be who you meet.
Please understand as you
go into this internship
maximize networking.
Shake hands,
kiss babies.
If you're a wallflower,
don't even do internships.
Not the classic way.
Obviously, you have
a skill to learn.
You're lucky enough
to be a developer
or something like that but fine.
But if you're an intern,
please understand it is
the human connections
that you're gonna make.
Way too many people
roll in and think they're going
to learn something
about advertising or
marketing or media or startups.
You're not.
You're just not.
Just saving you time.
And if you do,
it's just this much.
It's 3% of the equation.
Please attack the other 97.
Go to every after hours event.
Say hello to everybody.
If you go into an office where
everybody's head down,
it's not that kind of culture,
figure it out.
Hack it.
Be the obnoxious intern
that was too bubbly.
And make sure you
attach yourself,
even if you go into
an office, law firm
where everybody is head down,
if you see that
one person that looks up
and gives you a
glimmer of people skills
attach yourself to that person.
Let them bring you to things.
Interns, use this time wisely.
Way too many of you
go in and you think
you're gonna get something.
And in reality, the magic
was sitting right in front of you.
And the punchline, my friends,
is it's the people.
It's the people.
It's the people that you meet
in that office that go work
somewhere else, that are
reminded by your hustle
and tenacity and good natureness
and offense and you went for it,
you attached for it
you wanted it
and they're the ones that
give you the opportunities.
This is a very simple world.
This is a people world.
Not the black and white
skills you learned this
summer in eight weeks.
Half of you are going to get
coffee and do dumb shit
'cause they disrespected
you inappropriately.
So please, even if you
are in that 50% that's getting
dumb shit and coffees and
things of that nature,
say hello. Drop a coffee off
to somebody and they've
got a Cardinals pennant
and you know something
about the Cardinals,
say something.
Say something about
Adam Wainwright.
Create relationships.
It is the only KPI.
It is the only ROI of
an internship.